and you know life
good evening welcome to
welcome
um holidays
uh yes I've had apologies from Council
chalkin
um
uh first item is confirmation of the
Rangers for Place plates leadership in
Trafford and the re-establishment of the
role of director of HR I think Sarah is
going to take this item
thank you chair is that working
thank you um I I won't spend long
um introducing the report but
essentially what this report seeks to do
is to confirm and formalize
um some interim Arrangements that we've
had in place for
um
a little while I think now
um within the council initially
Arrangements that began as I went as
some of you will know went off on a
period of sickness absence for major
surgery and at that time a corporate
director estustion resources was
appointed to the deputy chief exec role
on an interim basis
and support Arrangements around that
role sarasala in that role including the
re-establishment on an interim basis of
the Director of Human Resources role
um if you roll forward then into 2022
those arrangements were continued
because we had some interim Arrangements
down in place or place-based leadership
in uh in Trafford as it was across the
rest of Greater Manchester there was a
holding position in place there for the
place-based leadership arrangements and
so
um having got to December 2022 do it was
confirmed that I as chief executive
would continue on a permanent basis as a
place-based lead or Trafford and thus we
seek to put in place the arrangements
permanently behind that with the deputy
chief executive confirmed and the
re-establishment of the Director of
Human Resource as well so I'm probably
not going to say much more than that
very happy to take any questions that
you might have based on the report
that's before you but to know that the
arrangements are to know thank you thank
you
thank you any questions this hour on
this item
it's about the retention of the role
going forward and getting
stronger 9 10 counts of the struggling
for attention
retention with that role
could you when you say retention with
the role in terms of
I'm I'm not complete so help me with the
questions I'm just thinking I had to to
obviously hopefully have the right
candidate in place
um what's the council doing in terms of
longer term retention to keep that
person
um because obviously it's such a clear
role and capitals are struggling with
that
I um I mean there are a number of from a
council point of view I think we
um we will go through a recruitment
process
um we we do have um
probably
um a difficult point to have this
conversation because I'm conscious that
the person who is um is doing the role
on an instrument basis very ably at the
moment is that to my left and are you
comfortable staying in and thus having
the conversation and so we will go
through a process in order to appoint to
that role but we do have a very strong
internal candidate
um for that role and
um I'll probably leave it at that at
this stage thank you appreciate it
thinking about it thank you come out to
everybody the director of HR is not a
statutory role
no it is
right without then no further questions
for Cyrus how are available if you want
to stay with us or you'd like
it's really about about the resourcing I
think reading the report it looks strong
because there'll be no extra costs
overall features of this reorganization
just to confirm the um the arrangements
that we have in place
um ensure that the NHS there is an NHS
contribution that um that contributes
both to the play space lead and
um to the supporting Arrangements
so summer if you've got somewhere else
you need to be that's fine thank you for
thanking for attending
thank you before we move on to the
director of Public Health recruitment
item can I just clarify uh the report
says this item is for an opening but as
the salary involved is a book Walkers
committee can improve the report we've
actually have schools informally synov
Council next week and I think you're
going to take this are you Angela
thanks Chad yes I'll I'll take you
through the report details
um okay so um can everybody hear me
so this report details the requirement
for us to recruited to a new directory
public health because the current post
holder has indicated her intentions are
tired in May this year
so as you will know this post is a
statutory post it's set out in the local
government and Housing Act 1989 and the
Health and Social Care Act makes it
clear that when we're recruiting to a
director of Public Health we must do it
jointly with the secretary of the state
for health
and
um it's it's important to note that when
I talk about the Recruitment and details
further on
so I think it's a key post I think we'd
all agree with that
um it's got a very important role to
ensure that the health of that
population is that accountable by
Council priorities and we want our
people our populations and live long
healthy and and their best lives
so the post and the post holders also
been instrumental in supporting our
responses and Recovery to the recent
housing pandemic and I think I wanted at
this point especially acknowledge that
and acknowledge the role that the
current post hold that Eleanor Rose has
played
um in leading and navigate singles
successfully through those challenges
um that we all faced at that time and I
want to make sure that we capture our
personal thanks I think it's those
gender reports as well but I wanted to
notice it in the minutes of this linking
um but her you know her dedicated
service her passion her enthusiasm and
her kind of leadership and assurance
that she demonstrated to all of us I
think you were involved in that at that
time period
so what we would ordinarily do and the
pose at this level is before we go out
to recruitment we just check what the
market is telling us which is what we
have done so we benchmarked with our
local Authority counterparts across
going to Manchester and we found that we
were actually quite low in our following
um levels
so this report proposes that we go if we
want to uplift the salary level to a
figure of up to 105 000 pounds and that
will help us to first of all hopefully
attract and retain a suitably qualified
able competent person and to take on
this really really important role and I
mentioned earlier about the recruitment
process because it's a giant post with
the Secretary of State we need to
include faculty in public health in the
recruitment process so we've been
liaising really closely with them
they've advised bills every step of the
way and what we need to do
we have an indicative recruitment
timetable hopefully the job will be
outside today depending on obviously
this this committee what we will do
because exposable Council on the 15th
February will go out initially with a
recruitment advertisement with a salary
level of up to 105 000 depending
approval
um
okay so stakeholder panels are in the
process of being set for dates in March
we're looking at a closing date about
the 26th of February and we have a final
panel
um with members and the faculty in
public health we're looking at
scheduling that in for about about 22nd
of March as I say we've been working
closely with the regional director of
Public Health Dr Andrew Ferber who has
been advising girls working closely with
us on the recruitment process I think
the other thing I will also reference in
big Council Bennett's referenced it at
the beginning of this meeting
we want to just ensure that the
um committee today says that we're fully
complying with our constitution
um we are asking employment Community to
approve the book list of the salary for
direction Public Health
posed up to 105 000 pounds
and to recommend the payment of the
salary for the director of Public Health
to Council of up to 105 000 pounds and
then to note the recruitment Arrangement
as if this reference in progress with
efficiency and Public Health
following that a report to council will
be provided and I will ensure that the
Strategic the exec member for strategic
HR is fully briefed
um so that the council decision criteria
can be met
okay with Paul's there and then do you
want to add anything
sorry I'll introduce Emma she's our um
head of legal and governance in post a
few weeks now yes thank you although um
I've been with the council for a number
of years
um but it's nice to meet you all and
thank you chair if I might just start I
appreciate that this um is a rather last
minute request and verbally amend the
recommendations in that report I think
it's fair to say that there has been a
period of reflections of what was
initially drafted a number of legal
colleagues have undertaken a review of
The Constitution and you know did some
ambiguity uh and felt that it was
important to take the safest and most
transparent position and to verbally
amend the recommendations to reflect
that the committee is asked this evening
to approve the payment list and to
recommend payment of the salary at
support Council and in relation to the
ambiguity in the Constitution we have
limited uh this will be taken up update
annual review of The Constitution to
hopefully prevent matters of this nature
arising again moving forwards
cancer acting
yeah I mean I I'm happy generally within
the report and the office that have been
suggested
um
can I just ask that the present post or
the owner
um indicated your intention to retire
this year which is
because obviously and you know we want
to make sure to get somebody in front
um before
absolutely Council of accident that's
one of the reasons why we're actually
doing the recruitment process here and
now and hopefully secure a good
candidate so that then there is a period
of Handover with the current post holder
um who can then you know higher of
knowing exactly the role he was in
foreign
service and it's been great to work with
even in my short time on the council and
I'm I'm also happy with the
recommendation I do know that I can see
that the salary that we were offering
was lower than you can see across um the
majority of places in GM just wanted to
ask what steps we're going to take to
attract someone of this calendar to this
role because it's obviously quite a
specific role and a very senior role as
well and I'm conscious that we might
find it difficult to recruit
and well hopefully one of the
um the things is obviously the salary
level we've adjusted the salary level in
reflection of where we were when we
recruited the previous post holder
and hopefully what we tell post hold
this so there's a candidate assessment
pack there's
um you know opportunities to speak to
you know development individuals within
the council to find out more about what
it's like to work the Trafford the local
Authority the locality I think you know
we have a certain reputation across
Grange management across you know the
northwest of the people which we will be
interested in coming to Trafford and
finding out more about what it's like to
work here
um
and I think you know at this stage the
we feel able you know and confident
so that we will attract you know kind of
the right the right individual
um at this point in time we also have so
many different
paternal
um candidates as well to work
potentially
as well so I think you know it's we
never know with these things do
things do the market like no that has
been some movement in this role over the
last 12 months and but hopefully the
salary levels the organization you know
kind of a reputation of who what we're
doing
um in this space will will help you know
how does it say we're offering lots of
opportunities for discussions to find
out a little bit more about how who we
are and what it's like to work here but
yeah hopefully we will do my workloads
to secure
um a suitable candidate for the role
yeah
anything further through on this item
thank you Angela on behalf of the
committee and also around to formally
record our thanks to Eleanor for what
was in an astonishing step what she had
to do and it's been wonderful thank you
I'm not aware of any urgent business
nothing's come to me so I've played
meeting closed and thank you all for
attending